السيد الرئيس الحادث أه
تحطم المروحية الذي نعتقد أنه
حادث نتمنى أن يكون حادث
لكنه أثار في ذهني وبالطبع
يجب أن يكون قد أثار في ذهنك
مسألة سلامتك
أم هل تشعر أن هناك  لا تزال
التهديدات النشطة المستمرة التي
تتزايد أه هل تقلق
بشأن أمنك كل يوم ،
لا أنا لست قلقًا من أن
الأمر هنا
جيدًا ، لقد صدمته ، لقد قلت
إنك قلت إنني آسف
لأنك لست بحاجة إلى رحلة  أنت بحاجة إلى
ذخيرة ، صحيح ،
لم يتغير شيء ، ما زلنا بحاجة إلى
ذخيرة ، لست محسّنًا لأي
شيء أجنبي
قلت الحوادث
أود أن أخبرك أنه
بسبب تجربة مجلس الإدارة التي
لدي الآن لدى جمعيتي الآن ،
هذا ليس حادثًا  لأنها
كانت بسبب الحرب ولأن الخنزير له
أبعاد عديدة ليس فقط في ساحة المعركة ،
فلا توجد حوادث في زمن الحرب ، هذه
كلها نتائج حرب على الإطلاق على الرغم من أن
كل شيء يحدث صواريخ
تضرب مدنيينا.
قُتلوا في رياض الأطفال
بالمدارس ،
قد يثق بي شخص ما قال إن
المعلومات التي تفيد بأننا نحن من
كان لدينا مدنيون على مرمى البصر
وكانوا يريدون فقط ضرب بعض
كتلة السلطة وهذا مجرد حادث
مؤسف وهذا مختلف
فقط كلمات فارغة
كل فرد كل فرد.  الموت
نتيجة الحرب